hey watch where the [ __ ] you going oh my
gosh i'm so sorry
oh i didn't see you had a baby there man
i'm sorry i ain't trying to fight nobody
with a baby
yeah hell yeah you won't
lucky [ __ ] huh well you're lucky
i'm carrying this baby
somewhere that look man you need to move
on all right i already told you
i'm not gonna fight you huh that's what
i thought punk
won't go cause we can go right now dog
what's going on all right man what the
hell are you doing man
what what what what trying to i can bob
and weave it what
you bitch-ass punk-ass [ __ ]
let's go come on man
come on no don't look at your boys look
at me man don't look at you boy
ow oh okay you think you hard
all right but you know what i'm gonna
show you what time it is right now okay
slap me right how about this huh now
what you're gonna do huh
now it's gonna do you ready because they
can do it right now cause i can take you
out man you're not gonna oww
oh oof okay
oh it's on now that's yep you did
you did excuse me i need this
yep
this what the what now man
what now let's go you know what
it's not even worth it man
that's what i thought so keep walking oh
okay that's about it that is vomit
oh dear